Genes provide the instructions and thus, the raw materials to make up your
cells, tissues and ultimately your whole body. That process of creation, called
development, is highly variable from person to person and especially in the
brain. Even small differences in how those cells and tissues are made can be
responsible for differences in personality, intelligence, moods, and even
vulnerability to mental illness. With that in mind, what do you think is the
most accurate statement about the connection between genes and behavior? Is it
that a few genes regulate most behaviors? A single gene controls a single
behavior. Many genes are behind any given behavior. Or, genes have no
connection with behavior at all? Go ahead and select the statement that you
think is most likely to be true.